welcome to the david pakman show i'm
farin cousins from ring of fire sitting
in for david today
we've got a lot to cover so let's hop
right into it first and foremost i want
to start
with where i am located the state of
florida
as everybody knows right now the state
of florida is watching as
covid absolutely ravages this state
to complicate matters in just a couple
days
next week most school districts
here in the state of florida resume
children going back to school virtually
no mask mandates in place and that is
thanks to an executive order signed by
our trump-loving republican governor
ron desantis just a couple weeks ago
desantis signed an executive order
expressly forbidding school districts
counties cities from putting any kind of
mask mandate in place and he followed
that up by the way
with a threat to strip federal funding
actually state funding excuse me from
any school
that implements a mask mandate
at the same time that this is happening
florida just two days ago had over 20
000 new coveted cases the second highest
day
on record for us we have had over 40
000 deaths in this state
alone the last week of july
we had more than 10 000
children test positive for covid19
our icu's are filling up
with men women and children as well
and desantis is sending everybody back
to school
and expressly saying you cannot
implement policies to protect these
children
that is what we are dealing with here in
the state
of florida there's a little bit of hope
though
right now we have several counties that
have decided to fight back
orange county which is the big uh area
of orlando it's where the theme parks
are huge population there
they decided along with broward county
down in south florida another
huge huge county that they were going to
defy
desantis and they decided to go ahead
and put the mask mandates in place
for school children now this was
actually before
desantis signed his executive order but
after his
threat of do not uh you know put a mask
mandate in place
so then after he signs the order
threatens to strip the funding broward
said well okay hold
up we're going to rescind the mask
mandate
we're not going to do it now we're not
going to go along with it
and then something amazing happened
several other counties
leon county which is where tallahassee
our capital is
they said we're going to do mass for
children at least for a couple weeks
alachua county said you know what we're
going to do the same thing
orange county of course was doing it
then after everybody else jumped in
broward county came back and said
uh you know what we are going to put our
mask mandates in place to protect
our children as they go to school other
school districts
are currently actually today having
meetings
about whether or not to put mandates in
place to protect uh
i think it's usually about k through
eight children
by putting mass mandates in place
obviously
if they hit 12 years old they're
eligible for the vaccine
but that's of little comfort to parents
who have children
basically sixth grade or younger at this
point
so what's happening now is they're
essentially daring
the governor saying we're putting these
mandates in place we're going to protect
these kids
you've told us you're going to strip our
funding
what are you going to do about it
basically playing a game of chicken with
this little
wannabe florida dictator and i love it
i love it not just because of the
political stance that they're taking
trying to say
you cannot you know have ultimate
authority
over every single aspect of this state
there are certain things that as a
school board as a county
we can do to protect our residents
but most importantly because the the
legal showdown
that if desantis chooses to enforce
any of his uh you know rules
this thing is going to go to court and
there
it's a mixed bag especially down here in
florida courts we have seen some
horrible decision come from some
ridiculously right-wing packed courts so
it's likely they could side with
governor desantis
it's also just as likely that in the
interest of the public's
health safety and welfare they could say
that no
the counties are exercising their
authority to protect
their residents again because of the
makeup of the courts not just here but
on the appellate level as well
it's a mixed bag and we really can't
predict or even pretend
to know what kind of decision we would
actually get
from any of these courts but we can hope
and i think right now that's probably
the best we have
because here's what's happening the
public
is actually starting to in in small ways
turn
on ron desantis who as we all know is
essentially at this point the heir
apparent
to donald trump's political apparatus
should donald trump not run for
president again in 2024
desantis has been rising in those
nationwide republican polls
but over the past couple weeks the polls
down here in florida telling us a much
different story
as it stands right now and granted i'll
give you this
there's one poll where desantis is now
losing to democratic rival charlie crist
who actually used to be our republican
governor
now he says he's a democrat but anyway
he's beating
ron desantis by one point in the latest
poll
45 percent crist 44 desantis and the
poll of course has a 1.6
margin of error and we're still 15
months out from the actual election so
the poll doesn't mean a whole heck of a
lot
but it is showing us
that at least some people here in the
state are paying attention they're
watching
as we have days where we literally have
tens of
thousands of people coming down with
covid where we send
thousands more to the hospital
because of this children are being
hospitalized at an alarming rate here in
the state of florida
and desantis would rather make this into
a political issue
than a public health issue earlier this
week
you know he got into a bit of a tiff i
guess you'd call it
with the white house because joe biden
called him out
uh said you know florida texas you know
either
do what you need to do or stay out of
our way so we can do what we need to do
to protect people
and desantis fired back at a press
conference said i'm gonna stand in the
way all the way
that means putting our kids in danger
another story came out this week from
politico where they
talked to administrators school board
members and principals from schools
across florida
and a lot of them told the same story
you know as i mentioned school's
starting in uh just
three days at this point
some of them don't have the staff to do
it either because they've had to bury
too many of them
in recent months due to covid or because
they have suffered massive outbreaks
once teachers went back
you know teachers always have that week
of pre-planning
everybody got exposed so now you have
schools that are going to start
some of them having teachers in the
double digits
out on quarantine they don't have the
staff to run their schools
once said we're literally losing our
workforce that is the quote
literally losing our workforce
and desantis won't let us protect our
our teachers or our kids
i'm hoping he backs off this but
honestly i don't think he will
because for him this truly is a
political
statement has nothing to do with science
has nothing to do
with the safety of people here in the
state of florida it's all politics
and he is pandering to the worst of the
worst
one of our sponsors is blue blocks blue
light
glasses i've sometimes had issues
falling asleep at night
eventually realize some of it might be
coming from the blue light
emitted by my phone and computer screens
peer-reviewed studies show blue light
can suppress the hormone
melatonin which can make it hard to fall
asleep because your
sleep rhythms are disturbed i've seen a
lot of improvement since i started using
blue light glasses from blue blocks most
companies make blue light glasses
in a mass produced way with no quality
standards but blue blocks glasses are
made in actual
optics labs in their australian
headquarters
they have over 40 modern frames you can
choose from they have a prescription
version
non-prescription even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses blue block
sells
they give a pair of reading glasses to
someone in need
you'll get 20 off when you go to
blueblocks.com
pacman the link is right underneath the
video and there's also
free shipping worldwide on orders over
115 dollars